on Monday a columnist at salon.com named
Brittany Tillich Rita's authored an
article titled Trump era anti-semitism
change in my family we started going to
synagogue the author says that until
recently she had quote considered myself
a non-practicing Jew a reformed atheist
he found my way back to some sort of
spirituality and began to embrace the
cultural history of Judaism that I was
raised with but she hadn't stepped into
synagogue in years until Trump Tillich
retox writes quote but then a news alert
came across the screen of my phone three
days before Trump's inauguration a
Jewish Community Center a few miles from
my home had been evacuated following a
bomb threat I felt my palms begin to
sweat as I stared at the notification
and disbelief jaws slightly slack not
here not now
anti-semitism which until this time in
my life has been only a theory instantly
became incredibly real even here in the
liberal bubble of Massachusetts hatred
is alive and well the JCC bomb threat
suspects it turns out were leftist
journalists in a Jewish teenager with
mental problems but the JCC threats were
merely an entree for Zilla krita's to
target the real anti-semites quote
anti-semitic hate crimes are at their
highest levels and years Jewish
community centers around the country are
getting bombed threats at an alarming
rate Steve Bannon an anti-semite is in
the White House swastikas appear like
hideous confetti decorating walls and
buildings all over the country Jewish
cemeteries have been vandalized and
while President Trump may have reminded
us about his Jewish family members and
assured us at a recent press conference
that we're going to see a lot of love
under his administration so far I don't
see it never mind we don't have any
suspects in the cemetery vandalisms yet
never mind abandon isn't an anti-semite
I should know since I'm an Orthodox Jew
who worked with him for two years daily
and think he's a garbage human being for
other reasons now I'm not going to
pretend that I wasn't upset by the level
of anti-semitic vitriol I received from
some Trump supporters during the last
election cycle according to the
anti-defamation league I was the top
journalistic recipient of anti-semitism
on Twitter by a wide margin I received
thousands upon thousands of overtly
anti-semitic tweets during the campaign
but that was not why I went to Sheol and
kept kosher or turned off my computer
for Shabbat I did all of those things
because Judaism is my religion and my
way of life I practice Judaism not in
opposition to anti-semites anti-semitism
but because Judaism has real true value
so what Caritas isn't actually
interested in Judaism she's interested
in redefining Judaism to mean lust ISM
and then saying that she's rededicated
to her left is Mbeki's of Trump to her
Judaism and social justice
warrior stuff an excuse to virtue signal
and push leftist values here how she
hears how she describes Judaism quote
now more than ever I want to teach my
children what it means to be Jewish our
faith has a long history of resistance
no matter how many times history has
tried to erase us wipe us out we have
survived
we have resisted our own demise and we
have fought for the rights of others our
people were active in the civil rights
movement and fighting alongside black
folks in the 1950s and 60s today my
family has black lives matter signs in
our home and on our shirts before my
oldest daughter could even walk she
marched with me as a Jew for the
Liberation of Palestine strapped to my
chest in a sling it is through
complacency that we can become
perpetuators of the oppression we were
once victims of via a vote for trump or
belief in marginalized people's ability
to bootstrap their way to success it is
returning towards instead of turning
away that we connect to our roots as
oppressed people and it is this Judaism
the one that centers the fight for
justice that I connect to it is the one
that finally makes sense instead of
turning away from our community we are
choosing to become part of it for the
first time in our adult lives unquote
this is horse crap Judaism is about a
particular set of beliefs and practices
it's wonderful that yous were active in
the civil rights movement and they
certainly called upon the Bible for
support so did Martin Luther King jr. of
course but marching for the Liberation
of Palestine while Palestinians murdered
Jews in the streets and Alexa moss is
not Judaic it's anti Judaic neither is
marching for the black lives matter
movement which castigates police and
makes innocent black Americans more
vulnerable to the predations of crime
and it's certainly not a Judaic concept
to shirk personal responsibility and
suggest that people can't rise in a free
society the Caritas article is only
important because it demonstrates that
for the secular left religious practice
is a charade it's just a way to claim
marginalization and minority status
rather than abiding by the dictates of a
religion that actually demands something
of its adherence if the creek us truly
wants to participate in Judaism you
should start with the synagogue and let
it shape her rather than the other way
around i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
let's turn into a very very busy news
day president Trump has signed an
executive order on religious freedom I
thought I would be celebrating
unfortunately I cannot because it's a
crappy executive order honestly god
president from - better than this he's
also not doing a great job on the
israeli-palestinian issue which I will
talk about + Trump care is going to be
rammed through the house and we'll go
through the details and what this crap
sandwich
looks like but before we get to all of
that enlightening and uplifting news we
have to and I would like to say thank
you to our advertisers over at wink so
if you are someone who doesn't know
anything about line if you're somebody
who is you have to go over to somebody's
house and wanna bring a bottle of wine
but you don't know the difference
between a bottle of wine and a bottle of
vinegar you need to go to try winked
calm / bend when you go to try wink calm
/ Ben they give you a survey and you
fill it out it's personalized to you it
ask you your taste in food and what you
want flavors you like to eat together
and then it tells you what wine is best
for you to bring over somebody's house
in for you to order for yourself they're
difficult honest or you don't have to
know Somali a from a hole in the ground
in order for you to understand how wine
works by going to try wyndcomm / men and
their bottles like $9.99 a pop so right
now if you go to try bling back home so
why spending at $20 off plus
complimentary shipping which is awesome
so you get two bottles that are
basically on the house if you do go to
try winked calm / bend and it is great
service obviously it makes a perfect
gift for Mother's Day by the way whether
it's a wink membership with ones that
are personalized to your mom's palette
and shipped right to herds or a
beautiful gift box you'll be able to
give delicious and unique wine to the
hard-working mother in your life or you
can get your mom a membership also and
then she can buy as much wine as you
want and given that you're her child she
probably wants to drink heavily in any
case try winked calm / Ben is the place
to get $20 off plus complimentary
shipping link comm for people who don't
know wine but want to look like they do
and want to drink some good wine in the
process everybody in the office has
tried the wink wine and they say that it
is excellent it's also why the
production quality on the show slipped
markedly in recent days as we put Austin
into a in any case what sits there
there's a lot breaking in the news today
and let's start with the Trump executive
order so yesterday I talked in sterling
terms about this executive order that
was going to come from President Trump
on religious liberty bump-bump about
giant fail so he brings out
the actual executive order the executive
order if it looked like the one that
they were looking at a couple of months
ago would have attempted to protect
religious bakers and photographers from
people attempting to crack down on them
for not operating for same-sex weddings
making cakes for same-sex weddings it
would have tried to exempt religious
organizations from the from the overt
antipathy of the IRS trying to crack
down on religious organizations because
religious organizations aren't pro-lgbt
enough that's what the original order
was supposed to do instead this order
only touches the so-called Johnson
amendment the Johnson amendment is this
amendment that basically says that it's
a piece of legislation that says that
the IRS is supposed to remove nonprofit
status from churches that speak overtly
politically and no one pays attention to
the Johnson amendment it hasn't really
been enforced in decades it's not
something that has a long history of
brutal repression attached to it it's
not great but it's not a huge thing and
Trump in that that's all Trump has done
so as I say the originally drafted
executive order would have attempted to
get rid of a lot of these regulations
that stopped religious people from
operating in the public sphere so there
are federal anti-discrimination laws
that say that grants is something that
Obama did that grants from the federal
government and and contracts from the
federal government can only go to firms
that do not quote discriminate against
the LGBT community this would have
stopped that for religious business
owners because if you're a Christian and
you own a business it's like a defense
contractor and you don't want to pay for
somebody same-sex wedding or somebody
same-sex health benefits that should not
be your fault you're a religious person
you have the ability to do that in the
United States nobody has a right to
health care from you because this is a
free country still I never understood
why this is a religious argument as
opposed to a freedom of association
argument you should be allowed to do
business with whoever you want to do
business with and not allowed to do
business with whoever you don't want to
do business with that's what the free
market is for if you discriminate
against people they will form their own
businesses there are other businesses
out there to take care of them honestly
if you can't find a baker that will
cater your gay wedding
then you're not living in the real world
there are lots of Baker's and a lot of
them are gay themselves and the vast
majority of Baker's will provide for
your gay wedding the same thing is
certainly true of wedding gown designers
and and photographers and florists it's
all ridiculous but in any case trouble
comes forward with this executive order
and
it's just garbage so CBS News reports
the executive order allows the IRS when
IRS officials choose okay so now they've
got selective prosecution going on not
to enforce the Johnson amendment which
prohibits nonprofits such as churches
and charities from directly or
indirectly directly engaging in a
political campaign but the order does
not provide blanket relief for
tax-exempt religious organizations
opening the possibility the IRS could
pick and choose whom to penalize at
Morrissey who's sort of a fan of
President Trump he explains that this
policy is actually the worst of both
worlds he says which churches will have
to worry about the IRS and a Trump
administration which churches will have
to worry about the IRS and future
Democratic administration this
arbitrariness does not provide stronger
religious liberty it takes us further
from the rule of law and closer to the
rule of executive whim Trump is out
there today talking about how his
Cardinals love it that's his words he
says Mike hired notes they're not his
Cardinals but this again is just a bad
piece of policy pushed by President
Trump so that's bad in other bad news I
want to talk about the the Trump care
thing in just a second because that of
course is the big news of the day in
other bad news President Trump has now
announced that he is going to Israel
he's going to visit Israel while he's in
Israel he's going to visit with Mahmoud
Abbas the terrorist leader of the
Palestinian Authority his long history
of associating with promoting
promulgating partnering with terrorists
he wrote his entire thesis when he was a
young man on I believe Holocaust denial
in any case Mahmoud Abbas is one of the
grosser figures in the world and Trump
is going to meet with him in Bethlehem
which is a propaganda coup for a boss he
met with him at the White House
yesterday and when he met with him at
the White House he flew the Palestinian
flag which is really gross you shouldn't
be flying the flag of the state that
doesn't exist and if it were to exist
would be a terrorist state and the fact
is that meeting with him in Bethlehem
this is one of the propaganda things
that Abbas and the Palestinians try to
say is that Jesus was a Palestinian
Jesus was a Jew gang Jesus was not a
Palestinian and the idea that the that
the Jews in Israel are just like the
Herodian villains in the New Testament
is asinine
Trump is forwarding that propaganda by
visiting with Abbas it really is quite
gross Abbas totally played Trump
yesterday it's obvious that he played
Trump castor day again I wish that I had
good things to say about Trump today but
he needs to do a good job in order for
me to say good things about him so
Malcolm owed Abbas the Palestinian
terrorist leader he he sits with Trump
and he says that
singing children are raised in a culture
of peace when ananassa via issue BM nino
hariya was Alan Mikkel Burpee at phylum
home one at fall and is radio mr.
president I affirm to you that we are
raising our youth our children our
grandchildren on a culture of peace and
we are endeavoring to bring about
security freedom and peace for our
children to live like the other children
in the world along with the Israeli
children in peace freedom and security
and Trump replies to that here's a trump
has to say about it let's see we can
fight yet is the direction it's say
something that I think is frankly maybe
not as difficult as people have thought
over the years but we need to willing
parties we believe Israel is willing we
believe you're willing and if you both
are willing we're going to make a deal
this is absolute horse crap it's not so
hard okay the Middle East is not so hard
you mean a religious conflict that is
now been going on for over a millennium
is not that hard I'm so glad the
president Trump is here just like Andrew
Jackson to solve the Civil War
I'm glad the president Trump here is
here to solve Middle East peace by the
way I boss is totally playing him this
is from Palestinian TV last year okay if
you haven't seen this is from
Palestinian TV because you're not my
problem is that LTS only a cop and I
would say there that nobody has any
jnanam is an imitation and it's you're
an Indian reality with them accession
opportunities to know even many of us
form our communities are young young
teenagers wearing the skin in milk or
jogging on ahead with a violation is
your usual
it's run by ocean it was abolished in
harmony and it's on there's William
McDonough spoken alongside a missionary
hello Bob is a really exciting show for
you absolutely must know right from and
you'd want to continue Joshua and
they're quick how you like
and for knives on American show about I
love God will regenerate their arsenal
another family we Revere Valley Oregon
and this is what's on Indian TV ok this
garbage is what's on Palestinian TV and
the fact that President Trump is sitting
there going well I think we can solve it
I think it's easy to solve no it's not
easy to solve and he says well we have
to willing parties and I believe you're
willing what makes you believe that
they're willing what makes you believe
that why are you even having a BAS to
the White House Abbas is clearly
presiding over terrorist regime Hamas
Islamic Jihad and Palestinian Authority
are in a joint government but Trump
because he thinks that he's smarter than
everybody else and in fact is really
really dumb on these kinds of issues is
getting himself in trouble it's very
very frustrating we'll get to Trump care
in just a second but first I want to say
thank you to new sponsors that we have
so did you know that 35 million American
families have no life insurance 0 it's
about 30% of all US households most
Americans think the life insurance cost
2 to 3 times more than it actually does
and almost half of American families
would have trouble covering an emergency
expense in excess of $400 that's why you
need to go and visit my friends over at
policy genius.com policy genius com it's
the best online life insurance
marketplace the most accurate quotes
from top a rated life insurance
companies I have life insurance on my
life my wife has life insurance if you
are a young adult and you have student
loans even you should have life
insurance that your parents don't end up
saddled with those student loans you
should always have life insurance to
make sure that you can take care of your
family or your loved ones in case
something bad should happen to you
mostly people in my audience young
people don't have life insurance that's
really dumb because if you're young you
have a you you want a beneficiary your
parents you're getting married or you
are married you have young kids you
definitely need to have a life insurance
policy that's what policy genius is for
they've placed over five billion dollars
in life insurance for people like me and
people like you they've a licensed
customer service team to help you find
the best policy at the best price and
you save 40% off other prices for life
insurance because it's basically a
clearinghouse instead of having to work
through a bunch of Asians they go direct
to consumer and that means they're
competing directly with each other you
save over 40% off other life insurance
prices go to policy genius.com pol i cy
g en i US policy genius.com no jargon no
sales
pressure nobody's going to try and
upsell you you just need the life
insurance that you need and that's what
policy genius.com is for the most
accurate prices and again you save a lot
over other life insurance prices we need
to the upper levels of life insurance
when you're talking about buying you
know hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars in life insurance and then you
can save up to 70% in some cases I've
been told policy genius.com
you should have life insurance my
recommendation to you just as a human
you should have life insurance and
policy genius.com
is the best way to do that pol I see why
GE and I US policy genius.com
check it out ok so the really big story
of the day beyond these kind of smaller
fails from the Trump administration is
of course Trump care so Trump care is
supposed to be up for a vote today it is
unclear whether it is going to pass it
is very very close
right now it's coming down to one or two
votes is it something people should vote
for you know I'm split on this on the
one hand I agree with the National
Review crowd that says that it's better
than Obama care on the other hand it's
still piece of garbage legislation and
now you own it I don't think that you
should vote for this I think the way
should do is you should vote for in a
straight repeal of Obamacare and then a
piecemeal replacement of Obamacare
having these omnibus packages where you
redo the entire health insurance system
and then suggest that it's yours this is
a big big big mistake so the fact that
you have the fact that you have them
voting for a couple of the things like
Medicaid reform and eliminating some but
not all of Obamacare taxes those are
good things but that's outweighed by the
fact you're not getting rid of the key
Obamacare regulations those stay in
place about pre-existing conditions you
are not getting rid of the mandate
everybody who talks about the individual
mandate goes away it doesn't really go
away there's a backdoor mandate if you
miss a year of coverage and then you
want to re-enroll the federal government
forces insurance companies now to charge
you a 30 percent surcharge in order to
punish you so that you don't drop off
your insurance plan until you're sick
and then rebuy it when you're healthy it
retains that new Ryan trump entitlement
program this of course is the refundable
tax credits to buy health insurance so
if you're poor then we just give you
some money to buy health insurance which
is basically an entitlement program and
it funds people not to buy health
insurance well healthy so one of the new
provisions in this particular bill which
comes from representative fred Upton
it's an amendment that gives states
eight billion dollars over the next five
years to fund high-risk pools but
essentially what it's for is people who
are trying to have who have pre-existing
conditions didn't buy health care didn't
buy health insurance and now want to
re-enroll and they're going to pay that
30 percent fine now we're going to pay
that for them so we're now incentivizing
people to stay out of the marketplace so
they can be eligible for that sort of
grant it's not going to be enough it's a
fig leaf it's just it is there's so much
wrong with this and it's all because the
reality is that Republicans lost this
issue the minute that they lost the
argument about the government's
involvement in health care to begin with
a free-market health care system is
still the best option here but nobody is
willing to say that because a
free-market health care system in says
that you are responsible for your own
health insurance that your community and
not the government is going to help you
out if you come up short on all of this
that has lost the argument and the
reason that that is lost the argument is
because of this emotional argument that
everyone quote-unquote has a right to
health care Jimmy Kimmel made that case
the other night I talked about it at
length on the show Sean Spicer at the
White House responded to that and he
said well Jimmy Kimmel is why we're
fighting to improve Trump care well I
think we share that concern for the
kimmells child as well as any child that
needs care and that's frankly why the
president fought so hard to improve the
bill like he did this morning to make
sure that there was an extra layer of
protection for anybody with a
pre-existing condition no matter of
their stage in life that's that's why
we're fighting so hard for this but I
think most importantly and I think at
the end of human Kennels monologue he
said that there is no you know we need
to have some of these things that aren't
Republican or Democrat that they're
American policies and I think that's
what the president is fighting for right
now okay the president is not really
fighting for the for what conservatives
would like he's certainly not fighting
for a free market in health care he has
always made promises that are not true
and the minute they say the government
is responsible for your health care
you're in trouble the left has
successfully made the case that free
market health insurance which is the way
that the vast majority of people in the
United States still get their health
insurance and it doesn't work
MSNBC's Jason Johnson's a good example
of this here's what Jason Johnson said
about about health care in the
government be honest if you want to talk
about elitism right you want to talk
about Oh Jimmy come on Olli you're an
elite if you don't have to depend on the
government at some point in your life
there are sick people out there there
are seniors who need federally funded
you know cars to take them to and from
places there are people who have student
loans there is cancer research from the
NF
that helps people throughout the entire
country so if you can say I don't care
about the government that must be great
and fine for you if you're that rich and
maybe the people in the White House feel
that way but regular people Republicans
and Democrats we're left how stupid this
is I can't wait for them to make this
mistake so they get wiped out in 2018
we've had some competent Republicans and
Democrats run in the country okay so
this is the idea the left wants to
pushes that we are all inherently
dependent on government this is not even
true in the healthcare spear so all the
talk about pre-existing conditions
ignores one rather crucial point there's
a point that avec Roy who is an expert
on health care policy has made his basic
point is that 90% of health care
policies already covered pre-existing
conditions you know this because if
you're covered by your employer health
care how many of you actually had to get
physicals in order for you to get health
insurance at this company the answer is
no if you are an employee of this
company then you did not have to take a
physical in order to get health
insurance that's because employers
bargain with health insurance companies
for group coverage right this is why you
have group coverage group coverage
covers pre-existing conditions ninety
percent of people have health insurance
in this country are getting it through
their employer and those people do not
have to worry about pre-existing
conditions because of this collective
bargaining arrangement that employers
have with insurance companies that's
basically a backdoor pre-existing
conditions ban that exists in the free
market the free market does work it does
work and when it comes to the individual
market first of all Medicaid already
covers pre-existing conditions but
there's no evidence that Medicaid
actually increases people's life span or
health outcomes so the idea that
Medicaid is what we should have Medicaid
for all as Bernie Sanders likes to say
Medicaid for some isn't even that good
so I'm not sure exactly why you would
want Medicaid for all again it's bad
policy but because Republicans lost the
conversation they're now going to lose
the policy and the fact is they're
coming up with this sort of
Frankenstein's monster of legislation
that keeps the central provisions of
Trump of Obamacare it turns them into
Trump care so somehow the Republicans
have come up with a magic trip that
turns a bomb that turns Obama's crap
into Trump's cap crap they've now done
it with the budget and now they're doing
it with Obamacare as well again
conservatism would be a nice a nice
response to all of this but
unfortunately I'm not sure we're going
to get it I do want to talk about some
stuff that was kind of bombshell that
the gyms can we drop the hearing
yesterday plus we have the mailbag
coming up but for that you're going to
have to go over to Daley wire com become
a subscriber $8 a month gets you a
subscription to Daley wire.com annual
subscribers get a free copy of Jaron
the arroyo fictional film set on the
southern border action western about a
rancher trying to defend his land
against the drug cartels is why we need
the Trump wall that is currently not
being built or funded daily wire.com he
can check it out right now or if you
want to listen later iTunes or
SoundCloud and make sure that you leave
us a 5-star rating and review we always
appreciate it we are the top
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you